bonjour Claude grange merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité ce matin vous êtes
médecin hospitalier à Dieu à Dreux
pardon vous avez fondé et dirigé l'unité
de soins palliatifs de Houdan c'est dans
les Yvelines et vous êtes l'auteur de ce
livre qu'on va voir le dernier souffle
accompagné la fin de vie écrit avec
Régis de Brice est aux éditions gallima
on va parler de la fin de vie avec vous
la convention citoyenne doit rendre ses
travaux ce week-end elle doit elle
devrait rencontrer Emmanuel Macron dans
les prochains jours on va parler de
votre parcours on va parler de la
manière dont on accompagne la fin de vie
aujourd'hui dans notre pays je le disais
vous avez fondé et dirigé pendant de
longues années cette unité de soins
palliatifs à l'hôpital ou dans les
Yvelines vous expliquer dans votre livre
que jeune médecin vous fuyez les
mourants qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré par
cette médecine
alors c'est vrai comme tout médecin donc
on est confronté à la mort de nos
patients et j'étais pas du tout préparé
à ça parce que dans mes études de
médecine on a peu évoqué la mort
dans nos études de médecine
qu'est-ce qu'on apprend à un médecin on
apprend un médecin à faire un diagnostic
un bon diagnostic et une fois que le
diagnostic est fait et bien de trouver
le meilleur traitement pour guérir mais
quel que soit les progrès de la médecine
et la science nous allons tous mourir un
jour et je pense qu'il est souhaitable
que des médecins et des soignants
puissent prendre en charge ces personnes
de la meilleure des façons le plus
confortablement possible ça fait aussi
partie des difficultés d'accompagner la
fin de vie en France que pour en
soignant accompagner une personne en fin
de vie c'est peut-être un peu tabouchédé
une personne à mourir c'est un échec
parce que vous avez été formé à guérir
tout à fait on a été formaté au guérir
et peut-être la formation davantage des
médecins que des soignants qui sont
davantage dans le prendre soin
quelquefois il y a des décalages entre
une pratique médicale et une pratique
soignante en tous les cas c'est ce que
j'observe et quelquefois donc on devrait
davantage écouter nous infirmières ou
nous être soignants
dans ces prises en charge et dans votre
âge vous formez à ça accompagner les
gens vers la mort oui donc moi je fais
de la formation depuis plus d'une
vingtaine d'années
parce que je pense qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire parce que
justement
moi j'étais démunie et beaucoup de
médecins sont assez démunis dans ces
prises en charge et donc ça passe par la
formation il faut un minimum de
formation pour être
compétent dans ces situations là c'est
difficile aujourd'hui d'accompagner la
fin de vie vous êtes médecin comment on
accompagne une personne tout en sachant
qu'elle va mourir dans un temps très
court
moi je dis souvent qu'il y a trois
besoins essentiels pour une personne en
fin de vie ne pas souffrir ne pas s'en
dire abandonner et de ne faire des
choses qui ont du sens que pour le
patient donc c'est mettre notre médecine
au service du patient et donc c'est le
malade qui décide et c'est pas moi
médecin qui décide ce qui est bon pour
le malade qu'est-ce qui vous disent
c'est malade alors il y a certains il y
a certains patients qui
[Musique]
sont au départ quand ils arrivent on
était sportifs quelquefois et ils
peuvent nous dire c'est plus possible
autant qu'on en finisse c'est le plus
vite possible
c'est un discours ça peut arriver mais à
partir du moment où on les soulage à
partir du moment où on rentre dans leur
chambre on les accompagne et à partir du
moment où on ne fait que des choses qui
ont du sens pour eux ils ne demandent
plus de
de les faire mourir que la qualité de la
prise en charge et de l'accompagnement
de fin de vie change la vision qu'ils
ont eux-mêmes de leurs morts et c'est
pour ça que je pense que face à ce sujet
là je crois que la solution pour les
gens qui vont mourir c'est le
développement des soins pallatifs il y a
pas suffisamment il y a on dit 21
départements qui n'en sont pas pourvus
en soins politiques on voit qu'il y a
que 30% des personnes qui
bénéficient des soins palliatifs
souvent on nous adresse les malades bien
trop tard parce qu'on continue à vouloir
encore faire des choses et déjà
commençons par ça c'est-à-dire que on
sait que dans la loi
l'acharnement thérapeutique on appelle
maintenant obstination des raisonnables
est interdite on ne doit pas mais on
continue encore beaucoup
s'acharner on va parler de la loi calme
et vous lisez il y a plus de 20
départements ou qui ne sont pas pourvus
en soins palliatifs comment vous
expliquer ces disparités territoriales
c'est parfois un manque de personnel à
autre chose il y a sûrement une question
de moyens et puis c'est vrai que on
manque de médecins on manque de
soignants et puis concernant les soins
actifs bien sûr que il y a une formation
spécifique à la prise en charge des
personnes en fin de vie c'est un rapport
qui a été rendu avant-hier par des
députés rapports sur la loi classe
Leonetti dont on va parler et ils disent
ils appellent à augmenter
considérablement les moyens à louer aux
soins palliatifs vous qui travaillez
là-dedans comment ça se traduit
concrètement quels sont les moyens dont
vous manquez et quelles conséquences ça
assure les patients par exemple mon le
service où j'ai créé cette unité
sportive à l'hôpital de Houdan donc où
j'étais le chef de service pendant une
vingtaine d'années donc là il y a un
nouveau médecin qui a pris la suite et
donc on manque d'infirmière on manque de
médecins donc les unités sont actives ça
coûte pas cher médicalement
et du personnel donc formé aux soins
c'est pas tant un manque de place un
manque d'équipements c'est vraiment un
manque de personnes
vont parler de la loi classe Leonetti la
loi classe Leonetti qui est autorise une
sédation profonde et continue d'abord ça
veut dire quoi d'un point de vue médical
qu'on comprenne bien alors donc d'abord
il y a plusieurs sédations il y a des
sédation transitoires toutes les
sédations c'est pas des sédations
profondes et continues jusqu'au décès
donc et là il y a trois critères donc au
niveau donc il faut que le malade est-ce
qu'il est consentant donc à faire une
sédation donc on fait pas des sédation à
l'insu du malade il y a des sédations
qu'on peut faire dans un temps déterminé
on peut mettre en place une sédation
parce que la personne vit des choses
difficiles et si on n'arrive pas à
soulager ces symptômes réfractaires on
peut la mettre dans un sommeil pour pas
qu'elle vive l'insupportable mais
quelquefois ces situations là sont
transitoires
et on n'a pas besoin toujours d'avoir
une sélection profonde continue jusqu'au
décès alors par rapport à la sédation
profonde continue jusqu'au décès souvent
on nous dit c'est une euthanasie
déguisée donc bah que Nini je veux dire
que la grande différence c'est
l'intentionalité c'est-à-dire que
s'il y a des personnes qui ont détresse
respiratoire s'ils vivent des choses
insupportables et que je n'arrive pas à
moi avec mes traitements apporter un
confort et bien on met la personne dans
un sommeil pour qu'elle vive pas à
l'insupportable par exemple de se voir
étouffer en pleine conscience
et donc tant que mon intention
c'est de soulager le malade
je suis sur le versant du juste son dès
que mon intention c'est de le faire
mourir plus vite je bascule dans le
versant de l'euthanasie et pour ma part
elle peut être mince mais elle reste
quand même très claire l'intention du
médecin du thérapeute est-ce que c'est
pour soulager un symptôme réfractaire ou
est-ce que c'est pour faire mourir plus
vite est-ce que cette loi laisse
Leonetti elle est adaptée à toutes les
situations
alors
il y a peut-être le fait que la sédation
profonde et continue jusque l'essai donc
il est dit que c'est pour des il faut
être atteint de maladie grave incurable
il faut avoir des symptômes réfractaires
à toute traitement et puis un pronostic
vital engagé à court terme et c'est
peut-être sur le court terme que là on
pourrait évoluer
parce que en plus ça le court terme
n'est pas défini le court terme on dit
que c'est quelques heures quelques jours
et peut-être que là on pourrait évoluer
sur ce côté là
ça peut être une évolution quel bilan
vous en faites ou de cette loi laisse
Leonetti est-ce que c'est un progrès
est-ce que c'est une avancée pour pour
les passions pour les médecins en tous
les cas pour nous médecins ça a été
quelque chose de très utile de pouvoir
bénéficier des sédations donc
transitoire et encore une fois on
utilise bien plus souvent des
célébrations transitoires et
dans des cas particuliers d'avoir en
effet la sédation profonde continue
jusqu'au décès et encore une fois j'ai
dit que
vous savez qu'on meurt le jour mais on
meurt la nuit
et on meurt plus souvent la nuit que le
jour
quand il y a une personne qui meurt la
nuit on accuse pas le sommeil de l'avoir
fait mourir
et donc on peut tout à fait
techniquement quand il y a des
souffrances réfractaires mettent la
personne dans un sommeil et va partir
tranquillement dans son sommeil et moi
souvent quand je fais des formations je
pose la question aux participants pour
vous une belle mort ça serait quoi je
peux vous la poser très souvent les
personnes ils disent moi je voudrais pas
souffrir
si ça peut se passer dans mon sommeil
ça m'arrangerait et puis surtout que ça
dure pas trop longtemps bon ça on a la
possibilité de le faire
est-ce que dans cette loi classe
Leonetti il y a aussi une meilleure
prise en compte justement de la volonté
de ce patient oui oui parce qu'il est
dit que le malade il a le droit de
refuser tout traitement et là encore une
fois j'ai dire que on n'a pas vocation à
faire survivre indéfiniment des
personnes une personne qui ne peut pas
boire et qui ne peut pas manger de
vouloir à tout prix
leur mettre des tuyaux pour continuer à
les nourrir artificiellement leur donner
des nutrition artificielle ou nitrateur
scientificielle quand on est dans une
situation d'une phase terminale ça n'a
aucun sens est-ce qu'il y a aussi dans
cette loi des dispositifs qui sont peu
connus ou peu utilisés comme les
directives anticipées alors les
directives anticipées en effet je pense
que il serait souhaitable que
tout le monde puisse à un moment donné
réfléchir sur si je devais être dans
cette situation là qu'est-ce que je ne
voudrais pas que l'on fasse et anticiper
ça pour les médecins pour les équipes
soignantes ce serait beaucoup mieux il y
a des personnes peut-être qui là sont
dans des EHPAD et on va faire des choses
que jamais ils auraient voulu qu'on
fasse
et donc de pouvoir chacun
rédiger ce que l'on souhaiterait
pas qu'on fasse pour nous est une chose
très importante et très importante aussi
pour les médecins et pour les soins ça
prend pas selon vous je pense que les
gens ils ont peur parce que la mort
c'est quelque chose de tabou on pense
que ça n'arrive qu'aux autres et de
réfléchir à sa propre mort c'est
peut-être aussi
stressant ou inquiétant comme si si je
les réfléchisse ça risque d'arriver plus
vite je sais pas mais je pense que ça
serait souhaitable est-ce qu'il y a
aussi un relâche un rôle à jouer du
corps médical peut-être une meilleure
information un meilleur accompagnement
je pense que chaque médecin pourrait
abandonner avec sa patientèle avoir le
temps pour évoquer ces sujets là est-ce
que aujourd'hui vous trouvez qu'il y a
trop de responsabilités qui pèse sur les
médecins sur cette question de la fin de
vie ou pas ou le bon équilibre a été
trouvé alors je sais pas si trop de
responsabilités mais avec ce qui risque
d'arriver et donc avec cette pression
sociétale où on dit que 8 Français sur
10 ou 9 sur 10 ils sont pour
je m'étonne qu'il y a la limite qu'il y
en ait pas 100% parce que ça dépend de
comment on pose la question ainsi vous
êtes atteint de maladie grave et que
vous avez des souffrances atroces ne
souhaiteriez vous pas qu'on vous fasse
une petite piqûre pour que tout s'arrête
à priori oui tout le monde peut être
d'accord mais là je dis souvent que ça
c'est une un questionnaire de de bien
portant moi il se trouve que avec ma
petite expérience avec toute l'équipe
soignante qui m'accompagne dans ces
prises en charge on a les personnes
concernées par le sujet
et bien je m'aperçois dans
[Musique]
22 ans 23 ans de prise en charge son
petit moi il me demande pas ça il me
demande plutôt de continuer à vivre à
partir du moment où ils sont soulagés
accompagnés entouré et à partir du
moment où on ne fait que ce qu'ils ont
envie que l'on fasse est-ce que ça veut
dire que pour vous il faut faire évoluer
cette loi ou avant de faire évoluer
cette loi il faut déjà améliorer la
façon de mourir en France et les soins
palliatifs alors c'est sûr qu'il faut
améliorer son mais moi je dirais que il
y a les gens qui vont mourir et les gens
qui vont mourir parce qu'ils sont
atteints de maladies grave incurable la
solution c'est les soins pallifs il faut
les développer après il y a un autre
sujet il y a les personnes qui veulent
mourir
et ça c'est les libertés individuelles
il peut y avoir des personnes et on
remarque quelquefois c'est des personnes
d'un niveau socioprofessionnel un petit
peu
élevé
parce que les SDF les ouvriers quand ils
arrivent dans une utilité sportive eux
ils pensent déjà être arrivé au Paradis
là tellement on les chouchoute on prend
soin d'eux mais il y a des personnes qui
vivent mal donc peut-être la dégradation
les pertes la perte intellectuelle de
plus pouvoir peut-être s'exprimer aussi
facilement de de la continence et tout
ça et que il souhaiterait partir avant
la déchéance soit mais dans ce cas là
c'est une demande individuelle
et bien
réponse individuelle je veux dire que
dont personne
peut se suicider le suicide n'est pas
interdit je pense que la plupart de ces
personnes ont la capacité de prendre
le médicament Haddock comme dans l'État
d'Oregon la la pile la dette pile ou là
je me rappelle plus comment il définit
cette pilule et
par contre il y en a peut-être un
certain nombre qui ne serait plus dans
la capacité de le prendre même et que il
y a une personne qui puisse
leur apporter le produit
et les aider à prendre ce produit là
peut-être que là au niveau du code pénal
que la personne qui assisterait
n'est pas les mêmes sanctions que le
criminel de sang ou d'enfant
ou que l'aide au suicide par compassion
d'une personne qui le demanderait qu'il
y ait pas la même peine que
qu'un criminel quoi mais du coup alors
est-ce qu'il faut parce que là les cons
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie va rendre ses travaux dimanche on
sait déjà qu'ils sont en grande majorité
favorable à l'accès à l'aide actif à
mourir favorable au suicide assisté et
66% en faveur d'une euthanasie 72% en
faveur du suicide assisté est-ce que
pour vous il faut aller vers cela
écoutez encore une fois moi je dis que
pour toutes les personnes qui vont
mourir c'est le développement des soins
en palettis maintenant que à cette
demande sociale il y a une réponse
sociétale pour les personnes qui veulent
mourir et bien peut-être qu'une
association
contrôlée
agréé et contrôlé par la loi puisse
prendre en charge ces personnes qui
veulent mourir comme éventuellement
l'association ou exit en Suisse voilà
mais moi je pense que ça devrait pas
rentrer à l'hôpital parce que ça va
faire un beans pas possible déjà
l'hôpital va mal de demander à des
médecins et des soignants te donner la
mort
parce que quand même c'est ça donc moi
je pense que donc ne pas faire évoluer
le cadre de la loi classique dans le cas
dans le cadre de l'hôpital dans le cadre
de l'hôpital mais maintenant
éventuellement pas faire peser plus de
responsabilités sur les médecins oui à
l'hôpital par contre qu'il y ait des
associations qui prennent en charge ceux
qui veulent mourir et pour accompagner
ces personnes là dans quelque chose de
structuré et organisé la DMD qui est une
association qui milite et qui a une
communication
qui ont gagné en tous les cas c'est sûr
le combat de la communication
et bien il pourrait prendre en charge
cette situation des personnes qui
veulent mourir pour accéder à cette
demande mais en tous les cas moi ce que
je veux dire c'est que
leur combat légitime tous ceux qui
militent à la DMD dans
mourir dans la dignité
je comprends leur combat il est légitime
parce que tous ils ont des histoires
personnelles où ils ont vu leur père
donc leur mère leur époux décédé dans
leur condition inacceptable tous
Nathalie
dans les 101 Vanessa Schneider dans le
monde voilà et ça c'est une acceptable
parce que la médecine elle a failli dans
ses prises en charge et donc leur combat
est légitime par contre la solution moi
je partage pas parce que ça serait quand
même un moyen très radical de devoir
tuer une personne
pour l'empêcher de souffrir quoi
moi je vois qu'on a quand même les
capacités de soulager les personnes mais
la médecine a failli dans ses prises en
charge et je pense qu'il faut développer
les soins pallifs par contre les gens
qui veulent mourir et bien peut-être
qu'il y ait une réponse sociétale à
trouver
est-ce que la fin de vie la question de
l'aide à mourir est suffisamment abordée
par les gouvernements par les politiques
et dans tous les cas là
ce débat de la conversion sexuelle a mis
au jour ça et pour vous c'était la bonne
méthode de faire passer ce débat par une
convention citoyenne je sais pas mais en
tous les cas j'ai voilà j'ai pas tous
suivi les débats mais avant c'était des
débats qui étaient un petit peu binaire
un petit peu tendu ou le et là il y a eu
des
concitoyens qu'on puisse changer sur
cette thématique et je pense que c'est
une bonne chose de pouvoir échanger sans
que ça soit une foire d'emploi et de
pouvoir oui tout à chacun parler de ce
sujet là ça met en avant
en effet cette problématique de la fin
de vie où on a encore des grands progrès
à faire et je trouve ça plutôt bien et
vous parlez de l'hôpital dans leur
rapport les députés ils disent aussi
qu'il faut améliorer la question de la
fin de vie à domicile pour que les jeux
puissent mourir chez eux ça aussi c'est
un angle mort moi je dis il faut
resocialiser la mort parce que
l'hôpital qui est quand même le lieu du
guérir devient de plus en plus le lieu
du mourir avec des médecins des
soignants qui sont pas forcément formés
pour ça
et je pense que
riche laboureur sentence à mort
prochaine il fit venir ses enfants et
leur par là sans témoins tiens je sens
plus mourir j'appelle mes enfants et
puis j'organise ma prise en charge alors
par contre ça peut être très lourd pour
les aidants naturels et il faut
absolument que les structures de
maintien à domicile que ça soit le SIA
de les services de soins à domicile ou
les achadés les hospitres de missiles
puissent accompagner les aidants
naturels pour que les choses se passent
le mieux possible
les sortir de l'hôpital ça c'est aussi
pour vous un grand combat et moi je suis
très favorable à ça un dernier mot
puisque c'est Emmanuel Macron qui aura
pour le coup le dernier mot sur cette
question est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut y avoir un débat apaisé et
qu'est-ce que vous pensez que le chef de
l'État peut dire on a un peu du mal à
comprendre quelle est sa position sur le
sujet oui parce que j'espère que
j'espère j'espère que
la solution ça sera quand même de
développer les sons relatifs parce que
vraiment on a besoin de développer les
soins pallifs et puis de trouver la
moins mauvaise solution pour ceux qui
encore une fois
souhaitent donc
mourir donc c'est leur droit mais encore
une fois ça rentre pas dans le cadre du
soin pour moi je souhaite pas que ça
soit à l'hôpital merci beaucoup Claude
grange merci d'avoir été notre invité je
remontre votre livre le dernier souffle
accompagner la fin de vie c'est avec
Régis Debré c'est aux éditions Gallimard
merci beaucoup d'être venu ce matin